so feminism which you've already
enlightened me a bit on you really
really are against feminism before I let
you do your piece now my sense is that
feminism at least the way it started was
that women wanted equality they wanted
the same equality of opportunity that
man had there is no doubt that most of
these roads in our society have been
easier for men I think you would argue
that that's changed now
but so what what do you think of the
feminist movie you were just kicked out
of the Amber Rose thought walk well the
picture you paint is perfectly accurate
or at least it was until perhaps 10
maybe 15 years ago so any recently has
changed very recently I think most
people instinctively agree with the
equality of opportunity and a quality of
access for women they want women to have
the opportunity to do anything they want
to rise as high as a man if they're
prepared to work as hard and put the
same amount of hours in and of course I
agree with that I think everybody agrees
with that that's not what modern
intersectional third wave is it's called
feminism is about which seems to me and
I think to a lot of women too primarily
to be about man hating it is a very
angry bitter profane lesbionic sort of
feminism right to be angry though I mean
oppressed class don't make you know
equal money as men are the wage is that
a myth it's one of those feminists
missed it won't die basically if you
take all of the earnings of men and all
of the earnings of women are you do a
simple bit of maths then you'll get
something like i77 right what this
doesn't take into account is different
choices that women make doesn't take
into account you know a variety of
factors no reputable economists takes
the wage gap seriously but it's repeated
because you know I mean we still this is
we saw where the stuff comes from just
this week SlutWalk I was kicked out of
journalists for Time magazine reported
that 15,000 people had come out in
support of this [ __ ] walk I was there it
was to like maybe 250 she blathered
you know started to sort of blame other
people and eventually they changed it to
thousands but was still wrong this sort
of like sloppy ideological reporting and
I'm sorry to say that the most brazen
untruths always come from the left just
like most of the major plagiarism
scandals come from the left because they
believe in narrative over fact this is
how rolling stone happened you know the
the the fake rape in rolling stone it's
how Duke Lacrosse happens it's how you
know all of these things happen because
these were liberal journalists believed
that even if this one's not true it's
very important for us to talk about
right so I'm with you on that because
even with some of my prior guests like
Sam and magic right this is what they
you know and they're getting a receiving
end of it you know these these memes of
like you know that's for whether it's
three four or five women one in three
one in four one in five women are going
to get sexually assaulted on campus
which is just nonsense whether it's the
wage gap is nonsense
you know these things become established
as part of almost omit they won't become
almost folkloric and roll up for the
president I mean Obama repeats some of
these statistics but they're not true
and if you look at the work for example
christina hoff sommers i mentioned
earlier the American Enterprise
Institute who do very crisply and
cleanly and entertainingly debunks this
stuff well she's great you should I mean
she takes a scalpel to these guys and
it's it's clinical and brilliant to
watch it um none of this stuff stacks up
so if you're trying to make the case
that women have a right to be angry that
they should be angry because women have
all of these in justices well ask you
what are these in justices and every
single one that's given by feminists
every example is given by feminists does
not stand up to scrutiny women are not
an oppressed class in the West there is
no rape culture in the West we don't
celebrate rapists we put them in prison
women don't earn less than men for the
same work that's illegal it is true that
you know because women and mothers there
are consequences when you get into the
workplace on that but a woman is paid
the same work as a man so we know when
you when you say there's a wait this
confusion between wages and earnings you
know when you say 77 to the dollar what
women hear is well I'm going to get paid
77 cents for a man's pound no woman has
that experience it doesn't happen you
know there's some women who work
part-time because they have children
well they have children what do you
expect you know the important thing is
that we make sure that when women come
back to work after they have children
that they're not disadvantaged for that
now where that's happening that's wrong
but it is
not it is not a problem on the scale of
what you know Sam Harris and Margit will
talk about you know happening to women
in the Middle East right you know and
feminists will never talk to you about
this difficult stuff because they don't
want to be they don't want to be put in
a difficult position of having to rank
Islam versus women right that's where
you are that Western world it's a
Western Western world Western feminism
complaining about man spreading
mansplaining this constant this constant
message that men are evil and broken and
wrong toxic masculinity this is
offensive it's irritating it is wrong
and it's destruction all right so let's
let's go right to that you wrote a piece
this week about this about the shooter
in Oregon yeah and your your piece
basically was saying that men are being
abused in the media or so are so easily
dismissed in society that that they're
acting out in in crazy ways and we have
to stop treating yeah man like what I
know and I know a lot of people on the
left for a lot of reasons you're
describing will read something like that
and say you know this is nonsense men
men have all the power
yep I mean what I said was that it at
least part of the reason that some of
these young men are acting out that we
have these shooting these shootings
happening at least some of the reason
for that is the horrible position we've
put men in now you can read every day in
major new media publications that there
is a there is a problem intrinsically
with being a straight white male or just
being a white man that somehow that
gives you privileged access to certain
institutions that you are somehow
problematic that's not the experience of
young men today who go through
university and are one in seven of them
is it who put on Ritalin or adderall
because they're held up to female beauty
female behavior standards it's not the
experience of boys there's a direct
connection between the medication and
the well of course there's of course of
course there is big behavior not be just
a misbehavior standards of course there
is behavior standards and we're not just
doing that but we're also changing the
way that exams are marked to make them
easier for women because women don't
test well in exams so boys are
struggling boys are falling behind and
this is not a
virtual thing everybody knows this boys
are falling horribly behind girls in
education fewer men are going to
university more women graduate group
moving at higher grades in the workplace
for example a Cornell study from 2015
showed that women have a two-to-one
advantage going for the same job just
because everybody is desperate to hire
women the experiences of men growing up
now do not reflect these horrible
headlines about straight white men and
frankly I think progressives have got
themselves into a really weird corner
they don't seem to appreciate the irony
of criticizing somebody for their skin
color and their orientation but they do
it anyway right and they what they would
say well this is the group that's in
power so if they're being well they
would say when wrongly claim that there
is a sort of mystical force and society
known as the patriarchy and what these
feminists will claim is that the
patriarchy is responsible for keeping
women down and all of these crazy
expressions like toxic messaging
whatever flow from this this tired old
ideology about male power and now as
Camille paleo that wonderful dissident
feminist critic says you know if society
be left in the left in the hands of
women we'd still be living in mud huts
thank God full of patriarchy it's the
patriarchy the goddess of the moon it's
the patriarchy to built the Internet's
the patriarchy that built this floor and
the ceiling women didn't want to do that
is the patriarchy that drives all trucks
and a steeple Jack so you know women I
want to do that stuff either we're
perfectly happy to complain about gender
representation when there aren't enough
women when when there aren't enough
women in it in a particular subject feel
for our arbitrary quotas but we don't
make it the same complain the other way
around men were the ones that were going
out and hunting and women were taking
care of the home so I find that
arguments a little flimsy there are
people who say that's not a bad way to
structure society I mean when we start
to break down those gender look this all
comes from the sort of discredited
leftist idea that gender is socially
constructed and if gender is socially
constructed right if you're taught to be
a boy or taught to be a girl rather than
having a lot of that behavior genetic
behavior sort of encoded in you if you
like as by virtue of your chromosomes if
you if if gender is a performance and
it's a social construct there's no
reason why girls can't behave like boys
and boys can't behave like girls now
we're beginning to start to see that
fall apart now one of the ways in which
it falls apart is the transgender debate
we know now now progressives are telling
us that people can be born with the
wrong brain if you could be born with a
female brain there must be such a thing
as a female
so surely you know femininity can't be
ascot via social construct make your
bloody minds up yeah and this was that
you know everybody was saying that Abby
or most sane people I think we're saying
that obviously Rachel Dolezal couldn't
choose to be black she was white and she
this is another shoe she was created by
progressives who said that blackness was
a performance that you could that
blackness was a social construct that
race was no that race is a social
construct of course it isn't you know we
know now because we have a computer
processing power to do it we know that
the you know when we look at the genome
that there are clusters of clusters of
information that map onto certain
geographies in that in that statistical
sense we know now that race is real and
here we know from ordinary people know
from the common sense of our eyes and
all years you know we know that people
look different and behave differently we
know that stuff but progressives for you
know a variety of barmy reasons best
known to themselves have been claiming
that's gender and race or social
constructs all this stuff is starting to
fall apart now it is the gender one
falling part I don't want to leave her
at this point but the general is fully
now believe that people can be trans
because III know some trans people I
have no doubt I didn't say that what I
said what I said was what I said was
transgender debates very interesting and
very dangerous for progressives and they
haven't yet dealt with this if you can
be born with the wrong brain if you can
be born if you come if you be born a man
with a woman's brain that means there's
such a thing as a woman's brain right so
what transgender patients will do is
they start hacking away at themselves to
make them you know and anatomically more
like women so they're you know somewhere
between the two genders by the end of it
right they're not functioning women but
they look a bit more like women and some
of their you know some things work a bit
more like women and they have the
appearance of women and they say they
have a woman's brain if you can have a
woman's brain there is such a thing as a
woman's brain means there's a biological
basis for certain behavioral differences
now you were asking me about sort of men
going out to forage may not may be no
bad thing that we'd let men be kuru you
know be the
hunter-gatherers and women may indeed be
happier focusing on bringing up bring up
children and building a home certainly
the women that I know the room in their
20s that have been told
especially in the 30s I've been told
they can have it all they can have a
career they're living in a horrible
apartment they don't like with a cat
that miserable I hate all their friends
they're not happy people they've been
you know they've been courage to be
single encouraged by feminism
particularly to look how they want some
this this fat butt fat positivity that
is another feminist trope is that you
can look like what you want the self
esteem shouldn't depend on what a man
thinks of you well yes it should because
if you want to you know if you want to
settle down with a manual like and have
a nice happy life there are certain
things that men liking women like stay
Finn you know and you may not like it
but it's a fact visual animals right now
some some guys like fat girls but not
many and if you're if you're listening
to feminists who are telling you can
grow blue armpit hair and you can burp
and fart and swear you can be Lena
Dunham this disgusting quivering mass of
horror you know and that men will like
you that's a lie well not like you'll be
alone and you'll be miserable I think a
lot of people here are gonna say well
this is sort of somehow this is some of
your gay rage or misogyny coming out I
don't have a dog in the fight I don't
care I don't care I don't care if you're
thin or fat as a woman I don't want to
[ __ ] you either way I don't care like
what I want is for people to be happy
and I see people not being happy because
I see that women are moving in a very
very dangerous direction told lies by
wacky far-left feminists crazies who
want to control other people because
they're hurting inside think a minute
minute cases very often it's 30 40 year
old bitter old women trying to lecture
20 year old girls on how to behave it's
an ugly woman on woman form of violence
if you like modern feminism it is a
nasty thing to watch and I see women get
drawn into this and I find it sad but
there is of course one great hope and a
silver lining to all this which is that
feminism is collapsing in popularity
among women in just a few years the
number of American women who describe
themselves as feminist has gone from 28
to 18% you can read in Vox right it's
not somewhere that would advertise
sisters although that may just be
because of the success feminists and
they don't identify as feminists because
they see in feminism were I see which is
it is turned into a bitter nasty ugly
man hating empty horrorshow
and frankly you read these blogs like
Jezebel which but you know which rail
against mint most women don't hate men
most women don't want to beat up on
people for being straight or being white
or being a male most people quite like a
boyfriend you know so they see they
don't have anything in common with these
angry gender warriors who want to deny
basic human nature and who make the
claims and give instructions that are
almost designed to make women miserable
yeah and I think most women recognize
that which is why feminism is falling
off a cliff with women